des abris de fortune et des hamacs
perchées dans les arbres ces militants
ont décidé d'élire domicile à l'entrée
du bois de la colombière 24 heures sur
24 et sept jours sur sept et on a
effectivement des gens qui sont dans les
arbres dans les hamacs haut perché et
puis qui observe qu'ils observent la
biodiversité depuis les cimes ensuite on
a des personnes qui sont au sol et
évidemment les ravitaillements des
différents collectifs des gens qui nous
soutiennent pas forcément en bloquant
par leur corps qu'on a fait c'est qu'on
a mis des vies ce à plusieurs endroits
dans les arbres qui sont plus ou moins
plus ou moins identifiables et toute la
zone a été balisé et il est écrit
partout sur les arbres qui sont piégés
l'intérêt de faire ça c'est que
maintenant les bûcherons on va avoir du
mal à venir si et ses arbres où ils
savent pas où il ya des bouts de métal
et ça pourrait endommager leur matériel
protégé ce plateau c'est le mot d'ordre
de sauvons beauregard un collectif de
défense de l'environnement
depuis le 15 novembre ses militants et
des notamment par extinction rébellion
tente de sauver cette tourbière de 9
hectares menacé par un projet de retenue
collinaire
objectif gagner du temps car à partir du
30 novembre prochain la loi protégera
certaines des 58 espèces présentes sur
le site au delà de cette date tout
chantier sera impossible
alors que le projet a été validé par la
mairie et par le préfet la déclaration
d'utilité publique elle n'a pas encore
été signé
ce qui donne encore espoir aux militants
c'est pas seulement la retenue de
beauregard on est nous notre slogan avec
les collectifs c'est ni ici ni ailleurs
donc c'est symbolique ici c'est un
endroit symbolique ils risquent de faire
la cuisine
le notre dame des landes des alpes quoi
en fait c'est voilà donc c'est un
message fort qui sans doute et entendu
de la préfecture et peut-être que les
hits pour s'adonner la déclaration
d'utilité publique et à démarrer les
travaux en fait selon la mairie ce
projet de retenue d'eau a pour objectif
d'assurer une alimentation en eau
potable mais surtout une production en
neige artificielle
car le domaine manque cruellement de
neige naturelle depuis plusieurs années
et subit directement les effets du
réchauffement climatique
plus de 80 projets de ce type sont en
discussion dans les alpes du nord dans
le cadre d'un plan à venir montagne
lancé par le gouvernement d'autres
associations de la région ont contacté
le collectif sauvons beauregard car elle
souhaite elle aussi mené des combats
pour protéger l'écosystème de leur
montagne